[Música]
muy bien el día de hoy los vengo a
invitar a la ciencia si desde los
chiquitos hasta los adultos a que se
involucren en actividades científicas
por los últimos ocho años he dado
pláticas en diferentes universidades
tanto aquí en méxico como en
latinoamérica con el objetivo de invitar
a los jóvenes a que se involucren en
estas actividades científicas
principalmente para que continúen con
estudios de maestría y también con
estudios de doctorado particularmente en
ciencias en sistemas digitales
sin embargo cuando llegaba a estas
pláticas y me presentaba con el grupo
les hacía la siguiente pregunta no se
supone que eran ya ingenieros casi
próximos a salir y les preguntaba qué
vas a hacer cuando termines tu carrera
y precisamente esto obtenía
silencio
duda no tics que van a ser les
preguntaba y todos temerosos entonces
después de las charlas yo me iba con esa
inquietud de por qué no me respondían
que iban a ser después de la carrera no
no no sabía si era por miedo e
incertidumbre apatía o tal vez los
habían llevado a escuchar la plática y
no tenían alguna algún interés entonces
cambié la dinámica y les pregunté al
revés bueno cuando cuando son niños aquí
como los niños que saben que les quiera
cuando son niños que les gustaría hacer
cuando sean grandes ahí empecé a obtener
más respuestas algunos no yo quiero ser
futbolista y levantaba más la mano no yo
quiero ser médico y levantaban mano no
arquitecto y les preguntaba les gustaría
ser científicos y algunos va así como
como bajando la mano pero pero temerosos
no conforme fui dando un poco más las
charlas esas manos iban levantando un
poquito más y también eso me llevaba a
la siguiente pregunta no les gustaría
estudiar un posgrado y algunos así
todavía temerosos de cien si no etcétera
no pero al final del tiempo que yo
estuve haciendo estas actividades he
observado que pues no es nuevo que
sepamos que es poca gente la que llega a
la licenciatura mucho menos que llegue a
la maestría menos un doctorado y mucho
mucho menos son son científicos pero
pero por qué por qué por qué por qué
está pasando no sí sí la ciencia es
honorable la ciencia es divertida sí y
también los nos permite dar una
respuesta a algunas algunas cosas pero
pero qué es lo que lo que está pasando
por qué por qué pocos quieren ser
científicos esa es una de las preguntas
porque pocos quieren ser científicos me
di a la tarea
y una fuente confiable a través de la
unesco dice que el 0 que el 0.1 por
ciento de la población global se dedica
a hacer ciencia se dedica de tiempo
completo a hacer investigación es una
cantidad muy pequeña de todos los que
somos que se dedica a hacer pero
entonces me seguí preguntando por qué
está pasando esto honestamente al día de
hoy no tengo una respuesta de por qué
está pasando esto pero tengo algunos
pensamientos y también esta misma
invitación a que todos nos involucremos
en la ciencia entonces qué está pasando
desde que somos niños nos nos invitan a
la ciencia los niños se están acercando
a la ciencia tal vez ahora sí está
pasando hay una hay unas ideas una
corriente de stem que es en lo que es la
traducción del español de ciencia
tecnología ingeniería y matemáticas
espero que con eso empuje pues los niños
o en un futuro los jóvenes pues si se se
emocionen se enamoren de las actividades
científicas y porque no lleguen a ser
unos
científicos sin embargo cuando yo estuve
en primaria cuando yo estuve en
secundaria eso no pasaba yo no recuerdo
que me hubieran hablado de ciencia o que
mira que las matemáticas te van a ayudar
en esto al contrario están las ideas
esto de las matemáticas nunca las vas a
usar
y en cuanto las vas a ver nunca de que
me van a servir no y porque las voy a
estudiar también hay un montón de
preguntas a mí no me tocó eso inclusive
me acuerdo que en secundaria hasta te
obligaban a participar en los en los
proyectos de ciencia no pero si no pues
tienen que participar lo aquí es esa
invitación a seguir seguir empujando a
los niños a la ciencia no de hecho hoy
invite a mis padres aquí están y son dos
personas que siempre me han empujado uno
de ellos me han dicho quieren hacer algo
hazlo ok entonces esa misma invitación
de ustedes inviten los a que se estén
participando en estas actividad
científica después dije bueno ok la
escuela es un lado pero por otro lado
muchos de nosotros hemos sido criados
hay unos que utilizan esta palabra pero
digamos influenciados por la tele y
ahora por los contenidos en 'streaming'
dije no yo pensaba no hay
contenido de ciencia no hay caricaturas
que hablen de la ciencia y justamente
estaba platicando con esto con mi esposa
que iba a venir a dar esta charla y le
decía lo mismo mira es que no hay
caricaturas que hablen de la ciencia y
abismo dijo está seguro ahí vamos al bar
a buscar al internet no me dé cuenta que
hay una lista gigante de personajes
científicos estamos hablando de tony
stark de hulk de donatello de las
tortugas de eremita debo esponja está en
series como mc 2 al cuadrado de exter
entonces hay una están en las
caricaturas de ciencia entonces si los
niños ven las caricaturas sus
superhéroes un científico me pregunta
sigue nos sigue que sigue pasando con
esto no entonces a qué se debe ser a que
entonces ser un científico es muy
difícil
si lo vuelvo a preguntar un menciona
doradito un científico es sólo aquel de
bata blanca loco es un superhéroe como
tony stark no tiene un edificio
millonario ese es un científico yo creo
que les quiero platicar que un
científico es una persona como tú como
yo cabeza cuerpo manos pies respira si
le gustan las actividades científicas
pero algo importante es que es formado
si como como un futbolista desde los 4
años está pateando un balón una
bailarina de ballet desde los 4 años
está bailando un abogado un médico o sea
todos tienen una formación lo mismo
sucede con un científico es formado no
es un genio que nace lo que lleva lleva
todo un proceso y eso es parte de la
invitación hacia la hacia la científica
no entonces yo aquí lo que también es en
estas invitaciones que le hago pues es
es llevar estas cuestiones matemáticas
un poquito a la vida cotidiana
entonces imaginémonos una pizza
qué podemos decir con matemáticas de la
pizza es redonda tiene salsa que va a
decir como que las salsas matemáticas
salsa ingredientes que bajo los
ingredientes es el pepperoni el queso
pero si lo vemos de otra manera la salsa
pepperoni y que eso se pueden ver como
textura se puede clasificar toda esa
clasificación que empieza a detonar una
serie de cuestiones matemáticas ahora
pensamos en la pizza si normalmente
viene dividida en ocho en seis y decimos
bien felices no me comí una pizza
completa o me comí la mitad de la pizza
pero por qué no decimos me comí tres
sextos de la pizza o me comí cuatro
octavos de la pizza y quiero decir que
me comí la pinta de la pizza no y no no
lo manejamos es a lo mejor se escuchará
muy nerd este a mí me tocó en la etapa
que el nerd era como como castigado el
nerd no era divertido y lo bueno es que
después de 20 años pues ahora está la
frase no never dies the new sexy no sé
eso está estar está bien pero
porque no podemos hablar así porque no
podemos decir este me comí los cuatro
octavos de pizza no entonces resulta que
también en todo lo que involucra comida
hay matemáticas sí en todo lo que nos
estamos relacionado no hay matemáticas y
tenemos que contextualizar no para que
los niños pues vayan viendo y de alguna
manera sientan que cuando lo están
viendo en la escuela en algún día esté
posterior lo van a utilizar no en mi
casa con mi esposa me ha tocado hacer
las listas para las fiestas del niño y
empiezo necesito tantos vasos no sé qué
empieza a hacer todo todo lo que vamos a
hacer de la fiesta de cumpleaños y todo
esto tenemos que comprar mis en serio
pero si no y de alguna manera a lo mejor
es un ejemplo muy sencillo décadas
etcétera pero pero todo se puede de
alguna manera de escribir con
matemáticas y dar y dar respuesta ahora
la ciencia es una forma de tener la
verdad lo que muchas de las cosas que
tenemos hoy en día fueron gracias a la
ciencia los niños los niños siempre se
han preguntado cosas porque el cielo es
azul porque hace frío porque los grillos
brincan
por qué por qué por qué y luego porque
mamá porque papá y ahí empezamos con
unas ideas de que a ya están en la etapa
del por qué y hasta es malo no no no no
no le digas y no le respondes pero
porque apagarlos por qué no seguir que
esos niños sigan preguntando y
preguntando y preguntándose es la
mentalidad crítica que debemos de tener
no y después tú como adultos siguen
cuestionando o yo por qué está pasando
esto y dicen no no preguntes no nos
quiten ese poder de crítica que de
alguna manera el científico sigue se
sigue alimentando entonces les decía con
la parte científica se han creado muchas
cosas esto que les decía de hockey
porque el cielo es azul porque los
grillos brincan
a lo mejor ahorita son respuestas muy
obvias para nosotros pero en algún
tiempo tuvo que haber una base
científica para darle esa respuesta pero
también los científicos pues nos han
dado la tecnología ahora tenemos el
internet sin el internet no tenemos
redes sociales no tenemos redes sociales
no hay tick tock no hay memes la verdad
ya les gustó este y pero que es lo que
lo que también está pasando yo creo que
hacemos un mal uso de esa tecnología que
hay que tener cuidado ahora si yo
comparto un challenge' estoy seguro que
todos los que se están viendo ese
challenge' se van a reír se van a
divertir y lo van a lo van a compartir
pero si yo comparto oye mira mi broma de
la pizza y mis tres sextos de pizza
estoy seguro que no me van a ver me van
a dejar en visto y no me van a dar like
si entonces esas son cuestiones que yo
lo sigo invitando a la parte a la parte
científica no y entonces si lo supe si
los niños supieran
y todas estas cuestiones tan tan
interesantes que se hacen a través de la
ciencia estoy seguro de que habría más
niños que les motive a ser científicos y
quieres que mira esto es gracias a la
ciencia esto es gracias a esto no
inclusive antes si usaba la frase está
de validado científicamente y ya con que
eso se dijera ya venía como que había un
cierto de tranquilidad no hace mucho que
yo no veo eso no entonces hay que
invitar a los niños con que siguen en
estas actividades los papás que nos
involucremos con las actividades
científicas y irlos orientando para
cualquiera de las áreas yo les hablo
desde una perspectiva muy de ingeniería
pero cuando yo me refiero a ciencia no
puede ser ciencias sociales ciencias
ambientales o puede ser este no sé
medicinas a todos los campos son
científicos no entonces esta es una
invitación muy abierta hacia ustedes a
que se sigan involucrando a la ciencia
no importa si son niños o adultos
o que estén en estas actividades y sin
más se los dice un científico en
desarrollo
[Aplausos]
[Música]